hello everyone it's seven o'clock this
is Sky News breakfast a big endorsement
this morning for Liz truss in the race
to be the next prime minister the
defense secretary Ben Wallace has given
her his backing last night she and Rishi
sunak were quizzed by Tory members for
the first time at a hostings in Leeds
with trust tax and even love Island on
the agenda we'll hear from Ben Wallace
in just a minute and the labor party is
facing a challenge of its own as unions
pushback after a shadow Minister was
sacked for making media appearances from
a picket line well we'll be joined by
that MP Sam tarry later on in the show
as another strike gets underway today
thousands of BT workers are walking out
plus the shocking new climate report
which says human caused climate change
made last week's record-breaking heat
wave at least 10 times more likely so
lots to come on a very busy show it's
Friday the 29th of July
a boost for Liz truss as the defense
secretary gives her his backing in the
race for number 10.
summer of discontent continues I'm
outside the BT Tower in central London
as 40 000 BT staff walk out
a new report finds human-made climate
change made last week's record-breaking
heat wave at least 10 times more likely
and with warnings of soaring energy
costs details this morning of how the
government's 400 pounds help for bills
will be paid this autumn
I'm live in Boston in Lincolnshire where
a merger investigation has been launched
following the death of a nine-year-old
girl from a suspected stab wound
it's decision day in the wagatha
Christie case Rebecca vardy and Colleen
Rooney will find out who's won their
High Court legal battle
grabbing the ball by the horns the
commonwealth games begin in Birmingham
this morning what will be the legacy of
the lionesses we'll speak to the manager
of a girls football club about how to
get more young women into the game
that's
[Music]
no more Neighbors after more than 35
years the final two episodes of
Australia's longest running drama series
will air tonight we'll speak to one of
the show's producers later on in the
program
[Music]
hello and a very good morning to you and
Liz tras has had a boost in the Tory
leadership race this morning with the
defense secretary Ben Wallace who
started as a front-runner to succeed
Boris Johnson backing her to become the
next PM well last night the foreign
secretary and her rival Rishi sunak
faced questions from Tory members in
Leeds in the first of the party's public
hustings the former Chancellor was
challenged over his loyalty and Accused
by one member of stabbing Boris Johnson
in the back
for me personally it got to a point
where I couldn't stay as the gentleman
previously also said I had a significant
difference of opinion with him on how to
handle the economic challenges that are
ahead of us and at a situation like that
there was absolutely no way I could stay
right there was no way that a prime
minister and Chancellor cannot be joined
at the hip with regard to Economic
Policy particularly at a time when the
economy faces real challenges so I was
left with no choice but to resign and
I'm sad that I had to but that was the
right thing to do and that was me acting
on my principles
well this trust meanwhile was asked if
she was the right candidate to win the
next general election
we need to win we need to win
and my friends we can win against kirst
armor who is a patronizing plastic
Patriot he is beatable but he is only
beatable if we deliver and I can assure
you if you select me if you elect me I
will work my socks off in number 10 to
deliver all of the promises we made in
2019
so let's bring in our political
correspondent Rob Powell and we're going
to hear from the defense secretary uh in
a few moments but it's a big endorsement
him backing Liz trust she'll be pleased
this morning won't she yeah it is a
significant endorsement Ben Wallace is
someone that's for a while have been
rumored that he might run he was
um according to polls anyway before he
had announced what he was going to do
pretty high up the list of preferences
in terms of Tory members so I think
you'd have to think that um his
endorsement will carry some sway amongst
the members that will start voting on
this
um in a few days time he's also written
a couple of Punchy pieces given a Punchy
interview in the Sun and written a piece
in the times as well where uh yes he's
talked up Liz trust and said that she's
authentic honest and experienced but
he's also taken a few swipes at Rishi
sunak as well and the manner in which he
left government when he resigned as
Chancellor obviously over Boris
Johnson's um conduct he said what would
have happened if the markets had crashed
that day and said he doesn't have the
luxury of walking out of the door so he
clearly thinks that Rishi sunak sort of
abandoned his post if you like was
missing in action and also said that he
didn't have he wouldn't have had the
luxury to do that because of his job in
charge of security and defense so
um yes an endorsement for Liz trust but
also a few swipes um at Rishi sunak as
well
um in terms of where we go from here I I
think it just adds to the sense of
momentum that Liz truss has at the
moment coming out of those debates where
um I think earlier in the week
um there was a sense that Rishi sunak
yes was trying to put her economic plans
under the microscope but had perhaps
overreached slightly in terms of the
tone in which he did it the aggressive
tone in which she did it and then I
think there weren't any of the game
changers that Rishi sunak needed at that
hustings
um last night now there's a long way to
go but in another way there also isn't
because ballot papers start landing on
Tory doormats from Monday I think it is
from the 1st of August
um and if people are voting early
there's only a really about a week left
to go to really start to change some
Minds so Rishi sunak needs to catch up
and quick and I think an endorsement of
this this type is not good for him and
only adds to the sense that Liz trust
frankly is starting to run away with
this right now okay we'll be fascinating
to hear Ben Wallace himself he will be
here very shortly the defense secretary
and so for the moment Rob thanks very
much indeed
so let's take a look at the paper and
according to the financial times
centrika the owner of British gas is
urging the government to give customers
more support with their energy costs
even though centrica's year-to-year
earnings have gone up fivefold
the guardian leads with the reaction of
trade unions to the profits as an insult
to working people
the express carries Rishi sunak's pledge
to deport more than 5 000 foreign
criminals out of the country if he
becomes prime minister
The Daily Mail goes with the closure of
what's being deemed an unsafe NHS child
gender Clinic
well the Daily Telegraph reports that
the NHS could be banned from giving
puberty blockers to children for fear of
rushing them into changing gender
and finally the psalm tells us that the
judge in the wagatha Christie libel
trial won't tell the two women involved
her verdict in advance in case it's
leaked
now workers at the UK's largest Telecom
provider and England's largest exam
board are walking out today in a dispute
over pay it's far from the only strike
action taking place over the next month
with the so-called summer of discontent
leading to walkouts across a range of
sectors
so sky is Madeleine Radcliffe is down at
the picket line outside the BT tower for
us now so Madeleine another strike tell
us what this one focuses on
CE again this is the first of two
strikes planned by some 40 000 BT and
open reach staff after they rejected a
pay rise of about 1 500 pounds five
percent now BTS say they will not be
reopening that pay offer and that pay
round and they will work to minimize
disruption but there are so many other
strikes planned this Summer that there
will undoubtedly be disruption we've
heard of the rail strikes there are more
of those planned tomorrow later in
August
Airline workers barristers exam boards
are also striking today so this is all
those workers really campaign for higher
pay more than inflation that inflation
currently 9.4 that backdrop they want
more higher pay Rises against this cost
of living crisis and will continue to
strike this summer so there will be
disruption even if today BTS say they
are working to minimize the disruption
caused by its workers striking
Maddie thanks very much indeed
now a new report has found that the
record-breaking heat wave that swept
across the UK last week was made ten
times more likely by man-made climate
change the scorching conditions caused
Mass disruption while wildfires
destroyed dozens of homes and now
researchers at the Copenhagen Center for
disaster research says the extreme
temperatures would have been
statistically impossible were it not for
global warming Aisha zaheed reports
last week's Heat Wave grip Britain as
record temperatures hit Tinder dry
conditions fueled wildfires this was the
aftermath
buildings charred and homes destroyed
the UK's infrastructure just couldn't
cope as air and rail travel was
disrupted and in the days that followed
grass fires continued
this is just some of the devastation
caused by the extreme heat and now
according to new research that
blistering Heat Wave was made at least
10 times more likely because of climate
change although scientists say that's a
conservative estimate because extreme
temperatures are rising faster than
climate models predicted and that's
causing concern among experts
without climate change they calculated
that this would have been an event that
might have happened once in a thousand
years they've calculated that with
climate change it was an event that
would only happen maybe one in a hundred
years but I think that they'll find that
actually it's far more common even now
due to climate change it's showing that
things are happening more quickly than
we expect what kind of Devastation could
we see as a result of all of this in the
future we know that for the next 30
Years things are only going to get worse
anyway because it won't stop until the
world gets to net zero emissions
but it also means that we are in
Uncharted Territory and we're in for
some nasty shocks and last week might be
just the first of several nasty shocks
we are going to experience
while the UK saw a startling new reality
during the heat wave none of it should
come as a surprise as scientists now
warn the consequences of the climate
crisis on this type of weather could be
worse than previously thought Aisha
zahid Sky News
well the defense secretary and as of
this morning Liz trust supporter Ben
Wallace adjoins me in the studio now so
you've come out and said that you're
going to back Liz truss why did you keep
that to yourself for so long were you
just waiting to see who was more likely
to win first of all I came out to
announce today we're going to do wrap
around child care for you know free wrap
around child care for all the men and
women of the Armed Forces up to the age
of 11 for their children so that's a big
1.4 billion pound effort to help
alleviate their cost of living as they
serve our nation so that's that's the
policy announcement today that's why
we're doing the media ran but look look
on the on Liz trust and my support for
her is you know I thought what I would
do at the beginning of this contest is
stand back I'm the sexual safe defense I
want to find a Canada that's going to do
right by the department and and
recognize that the threats we face every
day are very real and are growing and
that they need to be funded properly we
can't just sort of pretend they will go
away by themselves so you know I looked
at their performances I looked at them
on the hustings but I also know them
both I've been in cabinet for two years
with both the chancellor and indeed Liz
truss and so you know it's important for
me to to work out who I thought was the
right person to take us forward so you
know I know Liz she's very straight
she's authentic what you see is what you
get but also she has been very
consistent in the support for defense
and security she reads the same
intelligence reports I do so I felt it
was the right person to bet well yes she
has been supportive in fact she's
promised an increase in defense spending
to three percent of GDP but that's going
to cost between 20 and 25 billion pounds
isn't it she's also promising more than
30 billion pounds in tax cuts she's
promising to match NHS spending she's
promising to increase spending on Border
controls on the Northern Powerhouse I
mean if she was straight talking talking
and authentic wouldn't she spell out
exactly how she's going to pay for all
of that she has so first of all the
defense spending increase that is by
2030. that is saying that we need to
grow the defense budget to be on a three
percent of GDP by 2030 we're currently
declining we are we are forecast around
2026 to go below two percent of GDP
taking us from being the leader in
Europe to down to about eighth in
European defense spending which would
not be a sign of British leadership and
not allow us to keep ourselves and
indeed our allies safe so so the amount
of money that's needed right now for to
increase fence spending is minimal it
would actually start Rising
or so on on that commitment the funding
would really start rising in 2025 so
there would be time to deal with the
cost of living crisis that we have now
and to use what her commitments
currently are to to address the issues
so obviously her 30 billion pounds of
tax cuts are to not put in place a
National Insurance rise that has you
know only just or about to take place is
to suspend effectively the green levy on
energy bills because I mean that that is
not a let's say a cost to the executive
at the moment it's it's just saying that
we're not going to we're going to
suspend it for now but try and give
people uh a better you know to face
their bills but she's also said that
they are within the treasury's envelope
the 30 billion pounds they are within
the Headroom that she could use uh to
address some of the cost of living
crisis and I think you know that that is
right she's also said that the
alternative which is to win to keep this
very very heavy tax burden on people as
the oecd has said would have a
contractual effect on our economy in
fact shrink the economy because the real
way the real way we address our debts
and have the money to spend on
government is economic growth it's not
tax and spend it is grow the economy and
but the growth will take some time and
in the meantime she's likely to break
the government's own fiscal rules on
borrow no she's not she's not likely to
break the physical she's been very clear
about that and she's already said there
is Headroom within that envelope and I
think she has said that within three
years debt will start falling as a
percentage of GDP and that is the
commitment she will make but if we don't
grow the economy we simply won't have
the tax receipts uh even at the current
tax levels to fund what we need and I
think people seem to think that it's
very simple you just simply raise a tax
pay off the debt and go back that's tax
and spend economics the economics I'm
interested in is how do we stimulate
growth so cutting the right taxes like
not proceed with corporation tax Rises
helps us grow I mean when Rishi was a
Chancellor he cut entrepreneurial's
relief he cuts the relief that we give
to our entrepreneurs who've invested in
this country invested in businesses and
that's not a way to to to create either
wealth or indeed growth okay you talk
about authenticity but listross was a
liberal Democrat which is now obviously
a Tory she was a remainer now she's a
brexiteer so is that being authentic
yeah I think she's very she's been very
honest that's you know she's been you
know as she's gone through life as many
young people go through live I think
she's developed I think people develop
through life everyone uh you know many
of the people that are your journalists
or indeed your commentators some of them
even some of them in the mainstream
media some of them started lives as a
communist and are now sort of rabbit
Tories so I think what I would say is
people go on Journeys politically
because of their upbringing and and
their influence of their parents or
things you know she she often said that
when she was seven her her parents who
were left-wing took her to CND marches
you know doesn't make her a rabid CND
it's just part of the experience of
growing up and I think that's important
that we recognize people develop all the
way through their lives and that's not
about being inconsistent but I think
what I can tell you having sat next to
in the cabinet is that what you see is
what you get and something else that's
really important she's actually
incredibly experienced in government you
know she is the only candidate that did
nearly two years in the treasury as the
chief Secretary of the Treasury that's
the the number two position it attends
cabinets incredibly important to the
bookkeeper of the country she did that
job in the treasury she was then
international trade and negotiated trade
deals and now she's been a foreign
secretary that's a broad experience that
I'm afraid Rishi doesn't have yes he's
been you know in the Chancery but that's
okay that doesn't have that broad
experience well let's talk about Rishi
soon out because Nadine Doris the
culture secretary was on the show
yesterday and she suggested that he was
involved in a coup to remove Boris
Johnson is that how you see it I'm I I'm
not coming here to to attack the other
candidate my view is I Liz can sell
herself on her qualities I think she has
many qualities I don't I don't think you
know we're going to get into we don't
want this Blue on Blue I'm not sitting
here poking sticks at Rishi Rishi Suna
is they're very clever very capable
member of the cabinet or was a member of
the cabinet he he is you know he is you
know any government would be you know
pleased to have him in the government
but but fundamentally you know I'm here
to say well I think Liz trust is the
best candidate well you say you're not
going to criticize the chance on it but
you've been very critical of the
chancellor in the papers haven't you you
talked about him walking out you said
that you didn't have the luxury of
walking out well I said ministers don't
some ministers don't have the luxury of
walking out I mean if you're actually
looking if you look at that article I
was asked why I didn't resign and I said
some ministers don't have the luxury of
resigning because fundamentally we have
duties and obligations you know I have
myself and the Home Secretary for
example we sign warrants we we have a we
have a role in the operational delivery
of defending this nation she does
warrants Etc I I have to take
responsibility in operational
authorities and decisions around our
forces around the world so I can't just
sort of
junk it all in and walk out of water no
I didn't want Boris Johnson to go I
wouldn't have uh thought that was the
way to do it but I also made clear and I
made a tweet at the time that for those
colleagues who do want to to express
their lack of confidence in the
government there's a very simple way of
doing that there was going to be a 1922
a vote predicted on the Monday the next
week a couple of days after Rishi
resigned and they could have done it
that way they could have voted the Prime
Minister through confidence in the party
and you could have done it that's the
mechanism he said he said he couldn't
stay a moment longer while there was a
significant difference over Economic
Policy you say he was wrong to go no I I
just don't think triggering cabinet
ministers walking out at a time of a
crisis is the right course of action
there were other mechanisms to do what
they wanted if they if Richardson didn't
want the prime minister to be prime
minister there were other mechanisms to
do that and that goes for all the other
ministers I felt but you know you know
he made his choices he reconciles
himself with that you know I I'm there
to the end my job until I'm replaced by
a defense secretary and it's perfectly
legitimate that Prime Ministers pick and
choose their cabinet I have that
obligation not just to my leader but
also to the the men and women under
under the forces command did he really
leave the country in the Lurch I mean
another Chancellor was appointed pretty
much immediately well look you know
let's look at that Friday afternoon I
think it was a Friday what if the
markets had crashed what if there's a
what if the Home Secretary had done that
there was a terrorist attack you know
what what would the public think they
would never forgive us for that so I
just took the view my judgment was you
know well first of all I didn't want the
prime minister to go but but if I had
been in that position I think there was
another mechanism of doing it that was a
1922 procedures the following week I
don't think people needed to walk out uh
the public would would see that as a
government uh not thinking about the job
in hand and I think you know there were
there were many other opportunities if
they'd wanted to do it in a different
way you talk about economic emergencies
many would say we're going through one
now with the cost of living crisis we
learned yesterday new estimates for
energy Bills going to go even higher
than predicted a size 3 850 pounds a
year by January the current package just
isn't sufficient is it more has to be
done well I think we all recognize we've
got to try and do you know all of us do
our bit you know government has control
over some things like the like the levy
the the the the environmental sort of
precept that Liz trust has said she was
spent would suspend we all have a a role
in what makes a big difference you know
but there's also going to be a return on
people's energy bills uh that the
current government has helped deliver
and including uh the chancellor there's
going to be a return uh I think it's
being set out today how people are going
to get money off their energy bill I
think after 400 pounds but but you know
for 400 pounds a year ago was a lot of
money I mean it is it is a contribution
that the government can make obviously
get making sure that we unlock
investment into uh alternative energy
sources is incredibly important for the
medium and the long term so this is not
just a short-term problem we're gonna
have to deal with this in the medium
term and I think you know that I I
supported uh the government's plan and
Rishi cnx plan to actually put uh you
know the energy tax the the windfall tax
on earlier and I think you know that
that is the right place to go if if the
energy companies aren't investing in UK
capabilities so I think we are doing our
bit to raise money from the Energy
company is to try and alleviate the
pressure of course the problem is Energy
prices are going up and up and up and up
there are other measures that we're all
going to have to get involved in and I
notice countries in Europe already doing
it about energy saving measures what we
can what steps can we all take at home
to try and reduce our energy that is
that has got to be something we've all
got to contribute to but there is a
reality here which is a very difficult
problem for us all which is it is an
energy crisis uh born out of things like
the war in Ukraine around the world
where we have very little control over
it's why it's important that we see off
people like Putin that we make sure we
equip our Armed Forces to give the world
that stability and security because
without that security we will see more
of these problems and that's a long-term
aim but for now people need money should
the windfall tax be increased should
more money be gained from the windfall
tax we saw big profits yesterday from
sort of energy companies first first of
all the windfall tax itself is a is a
percentage so so if if they get more and
more money they're going to get more and
more they're going to be paying more and
more tax so so I think thing you will
see an increase in receipts from that
tax as they make more profits themselves
I think that is that is really important
we understand that I think what we need
to make sure is that we we constantly
explore the measures for the cost of
living but but look it's not just in in
energy it's going to be in food you know
there is global insecurity whether that
is in Ukraine or whether that's in the
Pacific
we're all connected today we're all
we're all Linked In This World uh covid
has been a global pandemic that we are
all dealing with the shock of it that
does mean there aren't any magic wants
it means that we all have to invest in
our resilience we have to invest in our
diversity of a supply you know we are
very lucky in Britain and while we are
going to face some very tough bills
energy bills in the future we are not
dependent on Russian gas like many
European countries who have no choices
I want I want to talk very quickly about
your brief about defense because as
Stephen lovegrove the UK's National
Security advisor has warned in the last
few days that the West risks an
initiation of nuclear conflict with
China or Russia because of a breakdown
of communication with two countries do
you agree with him well I went to Moscow
as trust to speak to our counterparts
just before this war we keep lines of
communications open uh I have met with a
Chinese Ambassador about a year and a
half ago and I'm you know he's right
that it's always important to talk to
countries even if you find it difficult
or distasteful or indeed you know it is
a challenge because there's a conflict
in Ukraine but I think fundamentally
that is not always the the real
component of why security is can be
imperiled it is often the intention of
the other country you know President
Putin has defied all logic in what he
has done in Ukraine everyone from his
friends to his adversaries advised him
not to do it from presidents to Prime
Ministers we we saw the legendary sort
of Marathon phone calls president
mackerel to Putin and he still did it
and that that's very hard because you
know when when someone just doesn't want
to listen to reason uh sadly you know
you end up in a in a very difficult
position that's where we are in Ukraine
a proper War uh you know the Russians
are failing at the moment on the ground
in many areas you know they've gone
Putin's plan A B and C has failed and he
your main look to plan D
um but you know it doesn't matter how
many times you say them it's not the
right thing to do you cut you can't just
get somewhere with warm words sometimes
you need warm words and I'm afraid some
hard power alongside it and and on the
subject of Ukraine Liz trust back in
February said she supported individuals
that wanted to go and fight there was
that a misstep on the world stage I
think what she was saying is it is a
very noble cause right I mean this is a
fascist State invading Ukraine I mean
the behavior of President Putin uh you
know where 2.5 million ukrainians have
been deported to Russia through
filtration camps where the war crimes
being were rapes and and pillaging
effectfully is going on where where you
know random civilian parts of towns are
being hit by missiles it is a noble
cause and I think what she was saying is
all of us feel that in this country all
of us look at our television screens
whether we're from the labor party
conservative party or even the SNP in
our house and think this is wrong this
is brutal this is on our doorstep I
think that's what you're saying okay Ben
Wallace thanks very much indeed for your
time and we did know what you said about
uh child care for military families
remind her that Rishi sunak and Liz
truss will go head to head in a live
televised debate here on Sky News Kate
Burley will be hosting that program on
Thursday the 4th of August at 8pm and if
you'd like to be a member of the live
studio audience and be in with a Chance
of asking a question please apply by
scanning the QR code which is on the
screen now or via the link on the Sky
News app and website
do you see where there's still to come
here on the show The Summer of
discontent continues as BT staff now go
on strike we'll speak to the General
Secretary of the communication Workers
Union down on the picket line that's
coming up a little bit later
also how will the port of Dover cope
this weekend as we head into one of the
busiest periods for channel Crossings
I'll be joined by the head of policy at
Logistics UK to find out how Freight
will be affected
and Labor's Shadow environment secretary
Jim McMahon will be on the show a little
bit later to talk about his party's
plans to deal with the cost of living
now police and Lincolnshire have
launched a murder investigation after a
nine-year-old girl died from a suspected
stab wound in Boston well Skies Fraser
Moore joins us from there now so Fraser
what more can you tell us about this
incident
well Lincolnshire police are giving out
very few details at the moment Anna
other than to confirm it was here on
fountains Lane in the center of Boston
and Lincolnshire that they were called
out at 6 20 yesterday evening to attend
an incident where a nine-year-old girl
had suffered a suspected Stab Wound
shortly after that police announced that
they were conducting a murder
investigation after the death of that
nine-year-old girl they say that her
family has been informed they're
currently being assisted by specially
trained officers and in terms of the the
situation here the geography of of the
area here very much in the commercial
part of of Boston there are very few
Residential Properties around here this
is an accountancy firm car park where
the police are just down there that's a
another car park so very few Residential
Properties around here and most of the
businesses that are here are either
closed permanently or would have been
closed at the time of this incident just
after six o'clock last night forensic
officers have been here until the early
hours of this morning we can see
evidence of that we can see yellow
forensic markers those yellow number
markers highlighting the areas of
interest to the forensic officer's
potential evidence that they may well be
gathering and we understand they'll be
returning here later on this morning to
continue their inquiries the local MP
Matt Warman he says he's spoken to the
policing Minister and asked for any
national assistance that may be useful
to the uh to Lincolnshire police to be
made available as quickly as possible
they say that this area will be sealed
off for the foreseeable future as their
investigations continue into now what is
a murder inquiry following the death of
a nine-year-old girl from a suspected
stab weird
Fraser thanks very much indeed
so let's take a look now at some of the
day's other headlines and with warnings
that energy bills could reach close to 4
000 pounds this winter the government
has announced details of How It's
promised 400 pound discount will reach
its customers the discount will be paid
over six months from October and those
who pay their bills via standard credit
payment card and direct debit will
receive it automatically
Britain's only children's gender
identity Clinic is to shut down the
Tavistock and Portman NHS Foundation
trust has been instructed to close
following criticisms over long waiting
lists as well as a lack of consensus in
assessments it'll be replaced by two
Regional Hub Services next year
in Ukraine officials say that a
counter-offensive against Russian forces
in the occupied Hillsong region is
gaining momentum fighting is continuing
in much of the country with reports of
missile strikes on the capital Kiev last
night
the UK's former ambassador to the U.S so
Christopher Mayer has died aged 78 his
six years in the post came during the
Clinton and George W bush eras the news
was confirmed on Twitter by the current
ambassador Karen Pierce
the state of emergency has been declared
in the U.S state of Kentucky in response
to severe flooding caused by torrential
rain at least eight people are known to
have died
London's fire chief wants a total ban
across the country on disposable
barbecues the call comes after the
London fire brigade experienced its
busiest week in history last week and
the fire commissioner warned of the
untold damage the Disposable barbecues
cause as we look ahead to a potential
second summer heat wave
and with parts of the world experiencing
extreme weather conditions let's take a
quick look at the impact of climate
change on the planet you can see there
are data Dash 4 the right hand side of
the screen shows how the UK's power is
currently being produced and the top
left is a crucial figure you can see
just how much warmer the planet is now
since the Industrial Revolution when
modern record keeping began currently at
1.25 degrees above that level the total
amount of CO2 emissions the amount that
we're pumping out into the atmosphere in
millions of tons down in the bottom
left-hand corner
now it's decision day in the so-called
wagatha Christie trial Rebecca vardy and
Colleen Rooney are due to find out who's
won their High Court libel battle the
case started off with an online spad
before heading to the courts for a legal
fight costing millions of pounds it
started in October 2019 in an out famous
Instagram post Colleen Rooney accused
Rebecca vardy of leaking full stories
about her private life to the Press
in June 2020 Mrs vardy responded by
launching libel proceedings against Mrs
Rooney Mrs fardy's lawyers claim she
suffered extreme distress as a result of
the Instagram post
and in the following November the libel
battle had its first hearing at the high
court in April 2022 the court was told
Mrs vardy appears to accept that her
agent was the source of allegedly leaked
stories
and in May 2022 Mrs vardy and Mrs Rooney
came face to face in court during a
week-long hearing
well the verdict is expected at noon
today and we will of course bring that
to you live here on Sky News when it
happens
now everybody needs good neighbors but
tonight viewers of the long-running
Australian soap will be saying goodbye
to the residents of Ramsey Street for
the final time after 37 years and nearly
9 000 episodes neighbors is coming to an
end with a final episode being broadcast
in the UK later on our arts and
entertainment correspondent Katie
Spencer reports
wow wow wow wow look at that as goodbyes
go get ready for a Nostalgia trip we
made it huh
I'm sweet home returning to Ramsey
Street to ensure neighbors get some
fitting send off some of the household
names whose big breaks came on the side
I love you guys so much
questions on your wedding Cody
funnier sunnier than its British
equivalents in the late 80s neighbors
pulled in around 20 million viewers but
with audiences down to a million and a
new commitment to original drama from
Channel 5 they pulled the plug calling
last orders at the Waterhole being best
man at a weddings big responsibility no
we don't know why it wasn't picked up by
a streaming Channel you know and to be
the first to yet to send another set
another Trend neighbors to set another
Trend and be the first soap to uh
transfer over to a streaming Channel but
it didn't happen
Charlene get out of there it was former
BBC One controller Lord Michael grade
who gave it its tea time billing some 37
years ago thanks to his teenage daughter
Alison who has told off for watching it
in her school break being the controller
of BBQ what were you watching because
you said we're all watching neighbors we
can't watch it because we're
oh I went into the office the next day I
said we're moving Neighbors from 135 to
5 35 so the kids can watch it when they
come home from school and the rest is
history as they say
from the dulcet tones of Angry Anderson
at Scott and Charlene's wedding to the
Psychedelic meanderings of bouncer's
dream not forgetting Susan's Sensational
slap I remember a woman calling out from
across the road in traffic just calling
out Susan Susan you leave that
like okay
fans have promised to fulfilling joyous
finale a reward for those who remember
it so fondly neighbors wouldn't have
lasted 37 years without the UK audience
we're very very appreciative and we hope
and pray fingers crossed that when you
don't watch those last episodes we will
have done the show proud and you'll be
satisfied with the way it ends we might
be leaving the street but we're always
going to be in each other's lives always
this final Slice of Life down under it
all goes so quickly the end of an era as
Fans Say good day to Ramsay Street for
the last time
Katie Spencer Sky News
coming up on Sky News breakfast I'm
going to be speaking to the General
Secretary of the communication Workers
Union as tens of thousands of BT staff
walk out over a pay dispute
[Music]
let's return now to the strike action
going on today workers at the UK's
largest Telecom provider are walking out
today in a dispute over pay will the
General Secretary of the communication
Workers Union Dave Ward joins me now
from the picket line so Dave Ward why
are you striking
yeah good morning Anna um well our
members this is the first strike in over
35 years across the BT group and the
reason that we're striking today is
because the guy who runs uh BT uh Philip
Jansen and the bald are ripping off the
workers and ripping off customers at the
same time so what we're seeing at the
moment is the company posting profits
last year of 1.3 billion pounds they've
just posted profits in the first quarter
of this year of 400 million pounds and
they've imposed a pay deal this year on
the workforce that is simply
insufficient to deal with the situation
with the cost of living crisis and you
know I'm going to say this today that
there needs to be some sort of inquiry
into the actions of of these balls that
are ripping off the whole of society at
the moment and our members are not going
to put up with it anymore
well yes and the BT boss himself though
says he thinks what workers have been
offered is fair and affordable he says
it Compares really well with any other
company and he said he's sad
disappointed that the strikes are going
ahead today he says that workers at BT
have been offered the biggest pay rise
for 20 years
well that's not true
um and the reality is is our members
never had a pay rise the year before
they had a one-off bonus and this year
what they've offered is is insufficient
I mean this is against the background as
well when I say that they are ripping
off people and our members are feeling
disgusted at the actions of the CEO and
the ball these guys he got a 32 percent
increase and I just don't think that
this is acceptable anymore today I think
every single one of your viewers will
understand that this level of inequality
in the way that workers are being
treated versus the companies themselves
they gave 750 million pounds to
shareholders before they then imposed an
inferior pay deal for workers this can't
continue people are not going to put up
with it
but meanwhile around the issue of
strikes there's been a lot of news
hasn't there the labor leader kierstama
sacked his shadow transport Minister Sam
Terry Terry who joined the picket lines
um hadn't he this week
um he said it was doing unauthorized
interviews with the likes of us here at
Sky News and was making policy up on the
hoof what do you make of Labor's
handling of the strikes
I mean look that's a matter for for
kierstama
um but I have to say that um from where
I'm sitting it looks to me like labor
wants to win an election without any
principles and I think people will see
through that over time I think our own
members will feel really you know
unhappy about the way that labor are
dealing with these things in these
moments you know when people are under
so much pressure you have to come
forward with policies you have to be
prepared to support working people and
if labor don't do that I think trade
unions and Community organizations will
fill that vacuum to stand up for working
people and that's what we're also
talking about you know we're also
talking about other forms alongside this
particular dispute and we're talking
about you know forms of collective
action uh later on in the summer that
all workers can participate in and we're
talking to other Trade union leaders
about that as part of a campaign for a
new deal for workers separate to this
current dispute
we
expand on that a little bit I mean
Labor's former Charlotte Chancellor John
McDonald said that he would support a
general strike where different
Industries coordinate action is that
something that you would look to do
well you know I mean the general strike
took place in 1926 our focus is on our
members primarily
and that is you know where that will
remain but let me say that at the same
time I do think that working people are
being let down across the political
parties at the moment I think they have
to come together in a different format I
would support a new social movement led
by trade unions Community organizations
to stand up for working people and we
are talking to other Trade union leaders
and the TUC about forms of collective
action that we could all take so you
know that that will probably start in
the next few weeks what would it look
like
well I think that's for us to have those
discussions uh I think there will be a
moment probably where we'll hold a press
conference and we'll be happy to talk to
you about what that looks like but I
think it's about making the government
uh act to support working people on the
cost of living crisis and all of the
things that are associated with that but
also to act against these type of
Business Leaders you know you can't
carry on it
letting these type of people live almost
in a parallel Galaxy let alone a
parallel universe and treat their
workers the way they are and they are
ripping off customers these guys
announced yesterday on top of 400
million in the first quarter profit on
top of the 1.3 billion that they are
going to put prices up which will amount
to 23 pricing increase in 12 months I
don't think anybody will accept that and
I would urge the government to do an
inquiry into the way that BT is running
this company okay and of course the boss
would say he's just looking after the
company and and its future which is in
the interests of the workers at David we
appreciate the time thanks very much
indeed for talking to us this morning
thank you
now as we've been reporting this morning
Liz truss has received a strong
endorsement in her quest for the Tory
leadership from the defense secretary
Ben Wallace and I was joined by Mr
Wallace a little bit earlier he told me
the foreign secretary has been
consistent in her support of defense
spending and an availed criticism of her
rival Rishi sunak he said that cabinet
colleagues shouldn't have walked out on
Boris Johnson
I just don't think triggering cabinet
ministers walking out at a time of a
crisis is the right course of action
there were other mechanisms to do what
they wanted if they if Richard Sherman
didn't want the prime minister to be
prime minister there were other
mechanisms to do that and that goes for
all the other ministers uh I felt but
you know you know he made his choices he
he reconciles himself with that let's
look at that Friday afternoon I think it
was a Friday what if the markets had
crashed what if there's a what are the
Home Secretary had done that there was a
terrorist attack you know what what
would the public think they would never
forgive us for that
now a giant ball the red arrows and
Duran Duran the commonwealth games has
opened in spectacular Style with a
celebration of its host City Birmingham
Prince Charles drove into the stadium in
a vintage Aston Martin and in his speech
that the games would create memorable
shared experiences Becky Johnson was
there
promised to be a celebration of
Birmingham
[Music]
a Showcase of its story from past to
present
[Music]
in the city of the car
a starring role for royalty Prince
Charles and The Duchess of Cornwall here
on behalf of her majesty the queen
[Music]
then the rule of the red arrows over the
Alexander Stadium
[Music]
foreign Birmingham rock legend Tony iomi
leading a tribute to a modern
Multicultural City
celebration of newcomers
that every child deserves the chance to
reach her full potential and pursue her
wildest dreams
[Music]
in the city of a thousand trades are
seen to recall the female chain makers
of the Industrial Revolution the woman
and the bull leaving behind the shackles
of the past a sign of acceptance of
moving forward watching from the city
center the crowd will wound
really impressive it's nice to see
Birmingham on the map to be honest I've
just learned so many things about
Birmingham already I didn't know
basketball was made here for example
athletes Welcome to The Stadium from 72
Nations and territories
it promises to be a games for everyone
inclusive diverse and vibrant embodying
the values of the host City Becky
Johnson Sky News Birmingham
now this weekend could see more delays
and disruption at the Port of Dover as
demand for cross-channel sailings is
expected to Surge in the coming days
well I'm joined Now by Natalie Chapman
from Logistics UK that's the trade worry
body for the freight industry a very
good morning to you and first of all um
kind of a nightmarish weekend last
weekend what in your view went wrong in
Dover well good morning Anna yes last
weekend was a real challenge we saw
Freight drivers stuck in the queue for
well in excess of 18 hours in sub cases
um it was a combination of factors it
was a busy summer getaway weekend which
had been anticipated for quite some time
and every weekend throughout summer
we'll see tourist traffic Peak but that
first getaway from the school holidays
is always the busiest
and the difference this year is um that
there's enhanced uh passport checks at
the border the borders are juxtaposed so
the French you go through French uh the
French border uh in the UK
um and there weren't the anticipated
number of French border offices that the
port of Dover had expected to manage to
pay that increase in demand and be the
increasing transaction times from those
enhanced checks on passports
so you agree with a number of of
government ministers who put the blame
on the French not turning up with enough
border officials do you because the the
French say this is about brexit this is
about the fact that passport control
takes so much longer now because
passports have to be stamped
undoubtedly it takes a lot longer and
we've seen challenges at uh at Crossing
down at Dover for many many years
whether it's been industrial action or
poor weather or we saw uh in uh
Christmas of 2020 many drivers spending
uh days on end in their cab um and that
was because of covid closing the border
so it's an incredibly fragile border
there are undoubtedly more challenges
and the transaction times do take longer
post-brexit but what we need to make
sure going into this weekend and every
weekend throughout the summer is that we
have sufficient resources so that we can
mitigate as much as possible those
additional checks and that additional
time that's needed
and are you satisfied that that will do
it is the current system fit for purpose
well we saw um last weekend the
challenge particularly on Friday and we
understand it on Friday night there were
very high level talks between the UK and
French governments and we did see
additional um border Force offices
deployed on the Saturday which helped
start clear some of the backlog but but
still was even busier than the day
before
through this summer we need to focus on
what we can do which is making sure
appropriate resourcing but looking
longer term
um you know looking to the 2025 border
strategy for example we need to make
sure that we can digitize as many of
those processes as possible and that as
much as possible can take place away
from the border clearly some checks will
still have to take place at the border
but if we can do as much as we can to
minimize any disruption because it's
such a key trade route for the UK but
it's incredibly fragile so we need to
make sure that it is as robust as we can
possibly make it
well Natalie Chapman will be keeping a
close eye on the situation at Dover for
the sake of those lorries trying to get
Freight through uh but also of course
for Holiday makers as well Natalie
Chapman from Logistics UK thanks very
much indeed thank you
do say with us here on Sky News
breakfast we've got lots coming up for
you in the next hour including this
trust secures a major endorsement in her
bid to become the next prime minister
more on that next
[Music]